we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P I want to continue
reminding you
there are people pretending to be me
trying to scam you on YouTube Here's a
new scam involving ps5s PlayStation
fives I think these are I think the five
is the newest one is it I don't know
I've never owned a PlayStation listen to
this
okay
yes my name is Brenda and
um I listen to you show a lot
and somebody contacted me saying through
you right that I won
um PlayStation 5 blah blah blah blah
blah no and my ID has been ripped off a
lot so I did not give him my address
good and I just want to know if it's
real no it is not real okay so I've told
you many times before
I don't want you to text me okay if you
if you comment on you on YouTube and
then it looks like I'm saying hey cool
please text me it's not me all right I
don't want to chat with you on WhatsApp
if you're getting responses on YouTube
saying David uh saying uh uh sir or
ma'am I'm David please chat with me on
Whatsapp it's not me and I am not giving
away any PlayStation fives I'm not
giving away game boys Commodore 64s
Xboxes Xbox 360s Super Nintendo Nintendo
Genesis I'm not giving away Jaguar
Jaguar however okay I'm not I have no
Ataris or video game consoles to give
away
these are scams one thing that is
upsetting me
the people that are being targeted we
we've been investigating this the people
being targeted in my YouTube comments
oftentimes they will say in their
comments their age and it's usually
above 65. so there are now five people
who were targeted by these scammers on
YouTube who in their comments said David
I'm 68 and I watch you every day boom
thank you so much for your comment I'd
like you to text me next thing you know
they're getting scammed so few things
here maybe don't post your age in the
comments I don't need to know your age
when you leave a comment I'm not texting
just don't respond folks report them
we're reporting them as quickly as we
can but these are scams I'm not looking
to give away anything all right please
please please on today's bonus show oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money and everybody else that makes
money to find themselves as bad producer
Pat was sent my pillow pillows
and he is going to review them there's a
whole backstory to how he ended up with
the pillows instead of me okay we're
gonna get to that number two
one vote made a difference in a
Massachusetts house election after a
recount one vote had been miscounted
and it changed the winner
Amazon is being accused of stealing tips
from delivery drivers
and the baby whose parents didn't want
the baby to get quote vaccinated blood
if necessary during a life-saving heart
surgery has had the life-saving heart
surgery we will tell you what happened
what went down it's an incredible story
but the good news is the baby had the
procedure all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show it's really easy
to get access to the bonus show just
sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code
please no more Trump and you have to say
it with that tone when you type it in
please no more Trump that's the code you
save you become a member it's an amazing
thing and I will see you on the bonus
show in mere moments otherwise we'll be
back tomorrow with another new episode